Caption: so it's now my absolute pleasure to
Caption: welcome our amazing keynote speaker to
Caption: this stage I think it's fair to say the
Caption: entire committee was really really
Caption: excited when we confirmed that Karolina
Caption: stirrer
Caption: I hope icon is gonna be our keynote
Caption: speaker because she's someone that we've
Caption: all been watching and admiring for a
Caption: long time and certainly a lot of the
Caption: things that we've done as a committee
Caption: we've sort of tried to look to her and
Caption: the stuff that she talks about in
Caption: organizing conferences that are
Caption: inclusive as guidance so today
Caption: Karolina is going to be talking about
Caption: towards a welcoming web and I'd like
Caption: everyone to give her an enormous round
Caption: of applause and she are to welcome her
Caption: onto the stage
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: hello is this on
Caption: hello Perth how are you that's a little
Caption: bit quiet have you had any coffee today
Caption: how about we go one more time
Caption: hello Perth that's better
Caption: it was really great that ddd / started
Caption: with welcome to the country and i would
Caption: like to personally acknowledge that this
Caption: presentation is held on the traditional
Caption: lands in the new garden nation and i do
Caption: pay my respects to the elders past
Caption: present and merging so today we're going
Caption: to be talking about where the web is
Caption: today and where is it gonna be in the
Caption: future
Caption: the demand for innovation automation
Caption: true artificial intelligence and
Caption: disruption has never been higher and in
Caption: many ways technology has brought us
Caption: incredible advancements it contributed
Caption: to improving living standards rare
Caption: defined communications and amplification
Caption: of business opportunity and much more so
Caption: what are we wanted or not technology is
Caption: reshaping our world it's economics
Caption: culture democracy and society as we
Caption: speak and i think it's fair to say that
Caption: every single one of us in this room has
Caption: benefited for playing a part in this
Caption: digital revolution but i'm not here
Caption: today to talk about that i'm here to
Caption: talk about the pitiful sort of
Caption: technology and i'm here to talk about
Caption: the negatives and i'm here to take a
Caption: critical look at what technology
Caption: presents today so we are here today to
Caption: get a little bit uncomfortable
Caption: the cause of said disruption has been
Caption: significant we demonstrated that the web
Caption: had failed
Caption: instead of served humanity the
Caption: increasing centralization has ended up
Caption: producing a large scale phenomenon which
Caption: is anti human and I'm not gonna tell you
Caption: who said that just yet but we are going
Caption: to come back to this quote later within
Caption: the talk
Caption: so what's so unhuman about the web I
Caption: mean we just said that it contributed to
Caption: so many great things and we're all so
Caption: excited and it surely brings a lot of
Caption: positivity and innovation into the world
Caption: what's so anti human well technology
Caption: negatively effects mental health social
Caption: media especially is known to negatively
Caption: affect mental health through low self
Caption: esteem anxiety depression FOMO
Caption: feelings of loneliness which feels a bit
Caption: weird because there are so many people
Caption: that we can reach through technology and
Caption: the more time we spend on social media
Caption: the more unhappy we get technology
Caption: especially social media has also become
Caption: a platform for harassment victimizing
Caption: shaming trolling doxxing and that has
Caption: driven a lot of people away mainly from
Caption: underrepresented groups and I think
Caption: those examples speak for themselves
Caption: and I could go on personal data has
Caption: become currency sold to advertisers and
Caption: sometimes even weaponized to alter
Caption: election results like in famous
Caption: Cambridge analytic on Facebook scandal
Caption: in many cases if a product is free
Caption: you as a user our product data preachers
Caption: have become very frequent leaking
Caption: billions of users information such as
Caption: giants like Yahoo Equifax uber due to
Caption: their poor security practices and that's
Caption: not only specific for Silicon Valley it
Caption: happens everywhere and some of those
Caption: companies covered up those incidents
Caption: without alerting people who are
Caption: susceptible to those breaches until a
Caption: year later they had no idea in many
Caption: cases reality can be mended and
Caption: manipulated towards commercial goals
Caption: this is an example from an Australian GP
Caption: booking platform called health engine
Caption: that altered 20,000 patient reviews to
Caption: sound positive and this is the original
Caption: one the doctor I saw was terrible but
Caption: luckily I received another option
Caption: opinion and the receptionist nurse was
Caption: lovely which is why I would go back but
Caption: that became the receptionist was lovely
Caption: so you see the level of manipulation
Caption: this is only one example the tech
Caption: industry is toxic culture is actively
Caption: driving people away especially members
Caption: of underrepresented groups and this
Caption: isn't a problem that's unique to
Caption: technology it's something that prevails
Caption: everywhere but rampant and fairness is
Caption: something that's reported way more in
Caption: tech industry than non tech industries
Caption: accordingly to tech leavers study 78% of
Caption: tech workers report some form of
Caption: unfairness towards them accordingly two
Caption: new study by reveal on the point eight
Caption: percent of black women hold jobs in the
Caption: tech industry
Caption: only 6% of Fortune 500 chief executives
Caption: are women
Caption: 98% of VCS are white or Asian men 29% is
Caption: the average pay gap between men and
Caption: women 60% of women report unwanted
Caption: sexual advances in their workplace 30%
Caption: of women of color were passed over for a
Caption: promotion for no reason
Caption: according to github surveys 95% of open
Caption: source contributors are men so these are
Caption: just few consequences of that rapid
Caption: technological growth so in my opinion
Caption: our industry is really facing a crisis
Caption: trying to figure out well who takes
Caption: responsibility for this who fixes this
Caption: what should we do and one of the reasons
Caption: why we got here is because we've
Caption: disregarded the negative impact of that
Caption: fast-paced revolution we've become
Caption: complacent engaging in something that's
Caption: called an act of cultural denial which
Caption: is the process where humans avoid
Caption: uncomfortable realities like poverty
Caption: suffering injustice racial oppression so
Caption: in some ways we've decided to look but
Caption: not really see a dangerous form of
Caption: magical thinking often accompanies new
Caption: technological developments a curious
Caption: assurance that revolution in our tools
Caption: inevitably wipes the slate of the past
Caption: clean
Caption: so this place of comfort and ignorance
Caption: and complacency has led us where we are
Caption: we forgot our historical and social
Caption: context so it's necessary to have a hard
Caption: look at how this neutral hacker culture
Caption: has steered us toward a crisis of
Caption: democracy and human rights so when I
Caption: have a look at common ways of thinking
Caption: that contributed to this crisis the
Caption: first one is move fast and break things
Caption: and I'm sure a lot of you have heard
Caption: that before up until recently that was
Caption: the unofficial mode of social media
Caption: giant Facebook one of the most
Caption: profitable companies that exists
Caption: recently it has changed to move fast
Caption: with stable infra and sure in mystery
Caption: first to approach the software and
Caption: reliable infrastructure but in some ways
Caption: it has become a celebration of privilege
Caption: and lack of responsibility in the early
Caption: hacker culture apparently Facebook
Caption: admitted that sometimes it harms
Caption: democracy but honestly they've shown
Caption: little responsibility for that as well
Caption: lack of consideration for there was
Caption: real-life repercussions of technology
Caption: and hunger for more data an exponential
Caption: growth has had catastrophic results
Caption: because disruption isn't a free card to
Caption: bypass laws freedom's moral compass
Caption: civil rights human protections speed
Caption: doesn't want lack of responsibility
Caption: the second belief is saying that
Caption: technology is neutral and we've heard
Caption: that multiple times technology's neutral
Caption: we should avoid politics but
Caption: technology's not never will be and never
Caption: was neutral because people after
Caption: software and they design it with
Caption: conscious and unknown biases baked in so
Caption: their prejudice lack of education
Caption: inevitably will manifest itself in their
Caption: we're and their design and it will
Caption: impact people who use them this myopic
Caption: focus on what new what's new leads us to
Caption: miss the important ways that digital
Caption: tools are embedded in old systems of
Caption: privilege and power they reflect the
Caption: current political climate classism
Caption: racism homophobia and amplify them
Caption: tenfold because the world wide web is a
Caption: giant megaphone the third reason is
Caption: lacking to ethical education because in
Caption: many cases the technology oriented
Caption: curriculum doesn't really include any
Caption: kind of ethical training compared to
Caption: other disciplines like law or medicine
Caption: the focus that we have on technical
Caption: skills the prior to psychology social
Caption: studies ethics communication skills
Caption: categorizing them as soft and
Caption: unnecessary distraction and that
Caption: troubling dynamic really feeds into the
Caption: stereotype of an introvert hacker who
Caption: just wants to code and forgets that
Caption: human that technology is built by and
Caption: for humans so I did a little survey and
Caption: sure seven seven thousand responses
Caption: isn't statistically significant but it
Caption: highlights a pattern and a very
Caption: troubling one most of the respondents
Caption: highlighted their engineering or design
Caption: degrees didn't include any ethics
Caption: curriculum or subjects or they were
Caption: actually opted in they were in mandatory
Caption: 67% no ethics training whatsoever and
Caption: it's hard to imagine making informed
Caption: decisions and having conversations about
Caption: ethical implications in design and
Caption: software if we are lacking foundational
Caption: understanding of that subject we have
Caption: nothing to base on an ethical decision
Caption: making is like a muscle that has to be X
Caption: because it will atrophy so the above
Caption: examples of culture and algorithmic
Caption: pitfalls of Technology highlight that we
Caption: really have to become fluent in ethical
Caption: concerns to continue building that
Caption: welcoming respectful web that we all
Caption: want and we talked us about this a
Caption: little bit already exclusion homogeneity
Caption: racial diversity scarce not mentioning
Caption: LGBTQ a representation or inclusion of
Caption: people with disabilities and the
Caption: statistics on this show that it's not
Caption: getting any better despite all of the
Caption: noise surrounding that subject and a lot
Caption: of effort and we cannot succeed making
Caption: the web that's welcoming towards
Caption: everyone if the platform is built with
Caption: only a few with enough power in
Caption: privilege that's backed by structural
Caption: inequality because it is impossible to
Caption: empathize understand and design for
Caption: experiences we never had never seen or
Caption: never heard of because those people are
Caption: just not around us they're not in our
Caption: industry we didn't see them we don't
Caption: hear from them that's why we're
Caption: presentation matters and many design and
Caption: engineering problems could be avoided if
Caption: teams were more diverse diverse teams
Caption: challenge biases are more innovative and
Caption: productive and drive more positive
Caption: business outcomes so until everyone no
Caption: matter their ethnicity socioeconomic
Caption: background gender sexual orientation
Caption: ability can enter and prevail and tech
Caption: and use the products of tech comfortably
Caption: and reliably the web is not open and the
Caption: web is not welcoming so my question
Caption: today is how do we establish was ethical
Caption: how do we build this welcoming web and
Caption: what does ethic means these are pretty
Caption: big questions to me ethics really
Caption: focuses on answering a question of
Caption: should we in ethics defense and
Caption: recommends concepts of right and wrong
Caption: conduct and there's no code of ethics
Caption: for do web there have been attempts
Caption: there have been people who tried to
Caption: write something for a certain group or
Caption: certain meetup a certain organization
Caption: but there's nothing widely adopted it's
Caption: a very complex problem and the web is so
Caption: distributed
Caption: there's nothing undressing this problem
Caption: how do we figure this out how do we
Caption: figure out what's ethical how do we
Caption: figure out our values and guiding
Caption: principles and what we built for the web
Caption: well I spent some time researching and
Caption: trying to figure out what would my
Caption: ethical principles be and this is based
Caption: on the actual Declaration of Human
Caption: Rights and a few other resources that
Caption: are relevant to our problems in the
Caption: industry and I hope they can guide us
Caption: towards a better welcoming web so the
Caption: first ethical principle is human rights
Caption: and democracy because it's not a
Caption: question of when but how technology is
Caption: affecting democracy and sure tech
Caption: conserve democracy really well but it
Caption: also has empowered authoritarian regimes
Caption: to censor press or track them dissenting
Caption: citizens and actually enact legal
Caption: repercussions on them for example in
Caption: Turkey Twitter users were trialed for
Caption: sending some critical tweets about the
Caption: current prime minister Facebook
Caption: discovered thousands of innocent ads
Caption: that were affiliated with the Russian
Caption: with the election 2016 that came from
Caption: Russia and they were meant to spread
Caption: misinformation many algorithms including
Caption: Facebook and Google helped creating so
Caption: called filter bubbles so we'll never see
Caption: content that's disagreeable
Caption: which feeds in phenomenon that's called
Caption: confirmation bias and it furthers our
Caption: inability to make informed choices a
Caption: citizen's challenge fake content no
Caption: surprise we live in a post fact era just
Caption: a few days ago Google announced that it
Caption: will be launching a censored version of
Caption: their search engine in China where it
Caption: previously had no presence so they will
Caption: be collaborating with the government in
Caption: oppression of the Chinese citizens
Caption: Amazon just promised unwavering
Caption: commitment in providing facial
Caption: recognition technology to US government
Caption: after many other companies denied
Caption: providing such services knowing the
Caption: repercussions of that because tech its
Caption: support it's supposed to support and
Caption: improve the Civic processes on which
Caption: democratic societies depends so what are
Caption: the rules what are the guiding
Caption: principles for human rights and
Caption: democracy and technology
Caption: well ethical technology should respect
Caption: and extend human rights it should serve
Caption: and support democracy not challenge it
Caption: fight against the spread of
Caption: misinformation which is pretty rampant
Caption: these days and encourage civic
Caption: engagement
Caption: the second ethical principle is
Caption: well-being we talked about social media
Caption: and affecting our mental health and
Caption: there are more studies that show that
Caption: our cognitive capacity decreases as
Caption: hyper connectivity Foster's attention
Caption: deficit disorders and often those social
Caption: media services tap into toes creating
Caption: addiction social alienation anxiety
Caption: depression stress trouble sleeping
Caption: our current side effects of this digital
Caption: advancement but that shouldn't be the
Caption: case technology should be mindful quiet
Caption: companion to our lives helping us learn
Caption: than being an overbearing disrupter
Caption: hijacking our attention to complex
Caption: interfaces and tricks and addiction
Caption: patterns and if you're interested in the
Caption: concept of calm technology I would
Caption: strongly recommend amber cases book
Caption: entitled calm technology and center for
Caption: human technology because they speak
Caption: about that subject so ethical technology
Caption: in the spectrum of well-being should
Caption: require minimum attention again we want
Caption: technology that's helping us and then
Caption: moving out of our way
Caption: ethical technologies should inform and
Caption: create calm should work in the
Caption: background again not hijacking our
Caption: attention in our time that we might to
Caption: want to choose to spend otherwise and
Caption: respect societal norms deferred ethical
Caption: principle is security and safety and
Caption: that can span over multiple dimensions
Caption: from reliability of software against
Caption: hacking and ransomware to actual
Caption: physical and emotional safety of its
Caption: users data bridges have catastrophic
Caption: consequences and just in Australia alone
Caption: 2014 2015 over 700,000 people were
Caption: affected by data breaches 700,000 people
Caption: and those details that were leaked and
Caption: stolen and obtained can be used to open
Caption: bank accounts get mortgages put the
Caption: victims of those breaches at the risk of
Caption: police raids immigration issues
Caption: financial bottlenecks of different sorts
Caption: for years to come and in other scenarios
Caption: that stolen data might put victims of
Caption: harassment and domestic abuse or
Caption: activists or whisperers an incredible
Caption: risk of daxing so ethical technology in
Caption: the spectrum of safety and security
Caption: should respond promptly to crisis
Caption: eliminate single points of failure
Caption: invest in cryptography and security
Caption: practices and most of all protect the
Caption: people who are most vulnerable the next
Caption: principle is responsibility and
Caption: accountability tech workers and
Caption: organizations have to be accountable for
Caption: their creations and they have to be
Caption: liable for the potential damages they
Caption: make on society and this hasn't been the
Caption: case and that social impact should be
Caption: estimated and measured with the same
Caption: level of scrutiny and level of
Caption: importance as delivering to your
Caption: investors or pushing new feature
Caption: releases or releasing a new product and
Caption: has to be done on continuous basis as
Caption: well sure significant of algorithms and
Caption: AI rely on machine learning but it is
Caption: humans who put that system in place and
Caption: designer so it's us who should take
Caption: ownership of those systemic flaws and I
Caption: think it's really important to realize
Caption: that fundamental distinction and the
Caption: fact that we can't put the blame on the
Caption: software recently Margaret Stewart who's
Caption: the VP of design at face book spoke
Caption: about the four quadrants of design
Caption: responsibility and she explained how the
Caption: liability of our designs rapidly grows
Caption: as products turned into ecosystems used
Caption: by thousands if not millions
Caption: which is very relevant to the Facebook
Caption: use case but no matter where your work
Caption: Falls and those four quadrants is
Caption: necessary to evaluate the potential
Caption: impact so ethical technology is aware of
Caption: diverse social and cultural norms
Caption: creates policies for algorithmic
Caption: accountability how this responsibilities
Caption: look like collaborates with lawmakers to
Caption: advance regulations it is so hard to
Caption: create regulations for this age of
Caption: technology and advancement the people
Caption: who are creating those regulations
Caption: really need our help and understanding
Caption: technology in writing laws for
Caption: technology to protect people and
Caption: complies with national and international
Caption: guidelines data protection and privacy
Caption: something really close to security and
Caption: safety the right to protection and
Caption: control over our personal data is
Caption: continually challenged one of the
Caption: examples of that as a service called
Caption: just deleteme which is a directory of
Caption: web services and those services are
Caption: categorized by how hard it is to the
Caption: leader account or whether it's even
Caption: possible to leave your account and your
Caption: data associated with it open and closed
Caption: our surveillance has become the new norm
Caption: and it's challenging human rights even
Caption: in Australia
Caption: just recently Peter Dutton was calling
Caption: for right to access emails bank records
Caption: and text messages of citizens without a
Caption: warrant and without the knowledge of the
Caption: citizens and that's very troubling the
Caption: data can be used to enhance user
Caption: experience it can be used for good and
Caption: it can provide useful services but can
Caption: certainly be weaponized by algorithms
Caption: authoritarian regimes and governments as
Caption: I mentioned before even creators of
Caption: facial recognition technology are well
Caption: aware of those repercussions and they
Caption: did decline to provide services to
Caption: governments because they know and they
Caption: understand what could happen
Caption: sensitive data should be accessible to
Caption: the users you should be able to modify
Caption: restrict access export and delete and
Caption: much it's AG web tsuki talks about data
Caption: collection in his talk
Caption: hunted by data in a really great way
Caption: don't collect it if you have to collect
Caption: it don't start it if you have to store
Caption: it don't keep it and he calls for those
Caption: minimal approaches to data collection
Caption: and mindful short storage times so
Caption: ethical technology should only collect
Caption: data that's necessary for operation do
Caption: you really need somebody's phone number
Caption: I don't think so
Caption: do you need their title to need all of
Caption: those details
Caption: you probably don't article technology
Caption: gives full control of data including
Caption: permanent and swift deletion some
Caption: servitors services will remove your data
Caption: after a month when you request that and
Caption: you do have to request that through
Caption: email that shouldn't be the case
Caption: ethical technology allows some level of
Caption: anonymity which is very helpful to
Caption: whisperers activists members of
Caption: underrepresented groups the next ethical
Caption: principle is transparency because
Caption: ethical design is transparent as has
Caption: nothing to hide and discuss an
Caption: information how services operate how
Caption: data is gathered stored and used really
Caption: improves trustworthiness and mitigates
Caption: misuse of that data often people who use
Caption: our software and designs and products
Caption: are not fully informed how they work
Caption: they don't understand how the services
Caption: affect them software is a black box and
Caption: they don't understand its decisions
Caption: those decisions cannot be explained so
Caption: that lack of clarity increases the risk
Caption: and magnitude of harm as well as lowers
Caption: the chances of any responsibility in
Caption: forensic accountability because there
Caption: are no governing bodies over privately
Caption: helped tech companies and startups so
Caption: those algorithms and software makes
Caption: choices that cannot be disputed or
Caption: challenged because how would we do that
Caption: so ethical technology responsibility
Caption: discusses abuses of software we already
Caption: talked about uber and about companies
Caption: that didn't discuss data breaches until
Caption: a year later this should be disclosed
Caption: timely and transparently establishes
Caption: rules for reporting and accountability
Caption: how can we report a breach what is my
Caption: job as a tech company or a tech service
Caption: how would I react to us what is the
Caption: process what can you expect expect from
Caption: me and thinking about mission and value
Caption: statements worried what is my mission
Caption: what do I present as a company as an
Caption: employee as an individual that
Caption: transparency is crucial
Caption: the next ethical principle is misuse and
Caption: bias awareness you might have heard of
Caption: Eric Meyer who is a very prominent
Caption: designer in the front-end developer few
Caption: years ago he wrote this article that was
Caption: entitled inadvertent algorithmic cruelty
Caption: and he described his absolutely horrific
Caption: experience with facebook's
Caption: year-in-review
Caption: that treated the death of his daughter
Caption: Rebecca as a highlight of his year in
Caption: 2016
Caption: Microsoft released a which was an
Caption: artificial intelligence chat bot on
Caption: Twitter which in less than 24 hours
Caption: turned completely racist and
Caption: misogynistic
Caption: and had to be taken down software that's
Caption: called compas that's used to predict
Caption: future crimes and chance of recidivism
Caption: has been proven by Pro Publica to
Caption: falsely flag black defendants as future
Caption: criminals at twice the rate compared to
Caption: white defendants simultaneously
Caption: mislabeling white suspects as low-risk
Caption: and these are just free examples
Caption: algorithms are thoughtless because
Caption: software is written by people and does
Caption: reflect their ideology biases thought
Caption: processes beliefs and so often we test
Caption: for those positive
Caption: cases successful use cases we forget
Caption: about malice and pathetic design and
Caption: more importantly the social context that
Caption: we're embedded in because software
Caption: doesn't learn we teach the software
Caption: technologies under design do not dictate
Caption: racial technologies rather they reflect
Caption: the current climate so ethical
Caption: technology is aware in combats
Caption: unconscious bias tests for misuse and
Caption: malice how the canvas product fail how
Caption: can somebody use this to exploit data
Caption: how can somebody use this to harass the
Caption: users of this application how can the
Caption: software fail ethical technology fights
Caption: against harmful societal inequalities in
Caption: the last ethical principle is something
Caption: that I've talked about quite a bit and
Caption: is diversity inclusion so the lack of
Caption: diversity inclusion is one of the
Caption: reasons why we find ourselves at such a
Caption: crisis and increase increasing diversity
Caption: inclusion is something that will help us
Caption: to build a more welcoming ethical web if
Caption: our team's organizations conferences
Caption: friendship groups we're less homogeneous
Caption: technological redlining in a form of
Caption: algorithms reinforcing reinforcing
Caption: oppressive social norms in enacting
Caption: racial profiling might have been less
Caption: much less significant because anyone no
Caption: matter their background the race their
Caption: gender level of ability deserves
Caption: equality and equity when automated
Caption: decision making tools are not built to
Caption: explicitly dismantle structural
Caption: inequalities their speed and scale
Caption: intensifies them because if our systems
Caption: are not effectively an actively fighting
Caption: exclusion they're reinforced and if
Caption: you're doing nothing you're reinforcing
Caption: it
Caption: so in that sense ethical technology it's
Caption: inclusive of all people it prioritizes
Caption: diverse teams and organizations it
Caption: prevents that technological redlining
Caption: that we just talked about and examples
Caption: that we've seen so how do we go about
Caption: those principles there's a lot of take
Caption: on there a lot of principles to be
Caption: focusing on surely there are some tools
Caption: of some resources that can help me in
Caption: focusing on ethics and building a
Caption: welcoming web last year's yielded quite
Caption: a few books on algorithmic bias and the
Caption: state of the tech industry
Caption: some of them include weapons of mass
Caption: destruction automating inequality
Caption: algorithms of oppression technically
Caption: wrong or reset by ellen power and these
Caption: are fantastic resources that will let
Caption: you understand more about algorithmic
Caption: bias about the impact of technology and
Caption: how to address that problem
Caption: there are some fun projects like the
Caption: tired cards of tech which is a deck of
Caption: tarot cards of amazing questions and
Caption: prompts about ethics and moral compass
Caption: that will let you make more informed
Caption: choices there are more structured
Caption: resources such as the ethical thinking
Caption: workshop that you can use at your
Caption: organization in a very effective way
Caption: that will guide you to making those
Caption: ethical principles be at the core of
Caption: everything you do whether it's software
Caption: design business decision making
Caption: and as much as manifestos and value
Caption: statements mean nothing if you don't
Caption: implement them and if you don't commit
Caption: to actionable goals they can serve as a
Caption: great source of inspiration and
Caption: education and this is an example from
Caption: Indy ethical design manifesto there's a
Caption: company that's really committed to
Caption: building an ethical web and there are
Caption: many more out there designers oath is
Caption: one of them and there's basically an
Caption: endless list of resources that could be
Caption: at your disposal to think what were my
Caption: principles as a company or as an
Caption: individual how do I start maybe setting
Caption: those principles will be a great
Caption: beginning to establishing this ethical
Caption: welcoming web practice
Caption: so I've sure to quote at the very
Caption: beginning of this talk and I didn't
Caption: attribute it and I want to come back to
Caption: it the anti-human web and if you don't
Caption: remember sir term berners-lee is the man
Caption: who literally invented the world wide
Caption: web and his recent interview with Vanity
Caption: Fair he expressed very negative feelings
Caption: and the fact that he's devastated by the
Caption: state of the web and what the web has
Caption: become but at the same time though he is
Caption: hopeful about the future he thinks we
Caption: can turn this ship around and I think so
Caption: too
Caption: and that's why I'm talking about this
Caption: and that's why I'm here today because I
Caption: can see this shift towards more humane
Caption: technology people first design empathy
Caption: it is happening but it doesn't need your
Caption: help because our common enemy is
Caption: complacency and turning away it needs
Caption: your help every single one of us in this
Caption: room no matter what your job title is
Caption: whether you're a freelancer employee
Caption: business owner CEO you can be anyone but
Caption: it's your responsibility and your
Caption: accountability for the culture and
Caption: technology you build we are all
Caption: responsible for what the web has become
Caption: today and it will become tomorrow
Caption: for this reason it is crucial to
Caption: understand those ethical challenges that
Caption: we talked about just because we have a
Caption: capacity to build something to design
Caption: something with the use of technology we
Caption: can fulfill our dreams of technology but
Caption: it doesn't mean we should that focus on
Caption: chasing disruption makes us forget that
Caption: those digital tools are embedded in old
Caption: systems of power and privilege and those
Caption: systems have to be challenged the web
Caption: shouldn't be negative the web shouldn't
Caption: be oppressive the web shouldn't lead us
Caption: to anxiety and depression and there's
Caption: negative places it shouldn't compromise
Caption: humanity the web should enhance our
Caption: lives fulfill our dreams not magnify our
Caption: fears deepen our divisions so today I'm
Caption: inviting you to carefully thing about
Caption: our responsibilities and the
Caption: ramifications of the work we do in the
Caption: web today I urge you to take action
Caption: let's build a better future together
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you so much I'm gonna be here like
Caption: playing with dongol sorry that was
Caption: amazing I really really enjoyed the talk
Caption: my main takeaway from it
Caption: I love the vision of having like ethical
Caption: technology that helps all of us equally
Caption: and enhances our lives and fulfills our
Caption: dreams because that is that's an amazing
Caption: vision isn't it and I guess what I took
Caption: from that is that all of us have a role
Caption: to play and I guess the responsibility
Caption: in making this happen and everyone in
Caption: this room does right because we're all
Caption: part of the tech industry yeah remember
Caption: that it's not only the CEOs or you don't
Caption: have to be a company owner or someone
Caption: doesn't have to consider you an
Caption: important person as every single one of
Caption: you if each one of us leaves this room
Caption: and does something ethical or changes
Caption: their values or making the industry bad
Caption: yes save my time the industry will be
Caption: better day by day I was loved don't
Caption: collect it don't store it don't keep it
Caption: because very simple but it's very
Caption: effective that's cool and I think you
Caption: know if all of us can help turn the ship
Caption: around and make Tim berners-lee proud
Caption: then thank you thank you so much Kelly
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: you